[Musique]
qui ici croit que les extraterrestres
sont cachés parmi nous pas trop ça va
deuxième question peut-être un peu plus
ce qui ici a cru que les aliens étaient
cachés parmi nous à l'ennemi par honte
n'ayez pas honte
et oui moi aussi j'ai cru que les aliens
été cachés parmi nous j'ai grandi à la
toute fin de la guerre froide avec x
files ou la scientifique était brillante
et rationnel est vraiment trop
cartésienne alors que le rêveur il est
un peu à côté de ses pompes mais
vraiment plus intéressant moi la vie
normale nous semblait bien ennuyeuse
alors j'adorerais la science et la
technologie ça allait avec la
science-fiction mais est justement la
science fiction il me semblait vraiment
trop lointaine et la vie la vie
quotidienne et bien elle manquait de
magie est ce que vous vous souvenez de
jacques pradel et quand même je suis pas
venu à ce point j'entends henin qui
rigole il y en a qui s'en souviennent
jacques pradel
il présentait l'émission du surnaturel
l'odyssée d'étranges avec la grande
révélation
les cassettes secrète de l'autopsié de
la lienne d'euros sous l hyper crédible
alors moi quand j'étais gamin je me suis
dit waouh mais c'est incroyable et j'ai
commencé à voir des émissions qui
remettait en cause ces vidéos oui mais
j'ai envie d'y croire moi cet alien
alors je n'étais pas prêt donc je suis
resté dans cette espèce d'état un peu de
semis croyances sceptiques pendant
quelque temps mais un jour il a bien
fallu que je me rende à l'évidence et je
me suis réveillé je me suis dit quand
même c'est qu'à cette vidéo qui aurait
dû changer l'histoire de toute
l'humanité qui tombent entre les mains
de jacques pradel plutôt que de
scientifiques un peu sérieux est ce que
c'est bien pertinents la réponse c'était
quelque chose du genre dessous bof
vraiment non c'était pas possible je
devais accepter la terrible vérité
ma télé pouvait me mentir et non
seulement le pouvais mais elle l'a fait
elle a fait le créateur du mannequin a
fini par avouer quelque temps plus tard
d'accord mais j'avais quelques indices
déjà à l'époque j'aurais pu me douter de
quelque chose quand même
cette conspiration fait d' alien de
sociétés secrètes et de scientifiques
tentant d'étouffer la vérité elle avait
bien peu de chances de tenir debout
alors pourquoi ça vous allez me dire il
ya l'univers est tellement grand il ya
bien de la vie ailleurs
justement ailleurs je vous propose de me
suivre dans un voyage pour comprendre à
quel point l'univers est grand et à quel
point cette rencontre du troisième type
avec peu de chances de se produire
ainsi nous allons nous équiper de
quelques outils d'esprit critique pour
nous défendre face aux conspirations
dans lesquelles les aliens arrivent sur
notre terre plate pour construire des
pyramides en compagnie des sociétés
secrètes
ça c'est la terre ce minuscule point un
peu pâle comme l'appelait carl sagan est
en réalité une énorme boule de matières
en orbite autour de notre soleil
ses très grands mais en fait c'est
seulement quelques milliers de
kilomètres de diamètre la terre c'est
concevable pour notre esprit
la lune est très proche mais vraiment
très proches c'est d'ailleurs le seul
astre sur lequel un astronaute à poser
le pied
il lui a fallu des jours pour s'y rendre
quant à mars notre plus proche projet de
colonisation nous parlons pour mars d'un
voyage de plusieurs mois
et en plus mars
pas très accueillant donc on pourra
peut-être trouvé mieux et si on allait
sur une exoplanète c'est à dire une
planète en orbite autour d'une autre
étoile qui pourquoi pas pourrait
ressembler à la terre difficile aussi
parce que pour se rendre sur proxima
centauri l'étoile la plus proche de nous
il faudrait un temps juste inimaginable
si vous preniez votre formule 1 des
spasmes pourquoi pas vous mettriez 13
millions d'années à atteindre proxima
centauri alors il ya 13 millions
d'années l'être humain n'existait même
pas donc pas top mais vous me direz et
si des aliens avait inventé un moyen de
se déplacer à la vitesse de la lumière
pour aller vraiment très très loin déjà
c'est absolument pas sûr que ce soit
possible et ensuite ça reste vraiment
très très loin pour vous en convaincre
je vais vous introduire un nouveau
concept payez pas si nouveau que ça mais
c'est celui de l'année lumière l'année
lumière c'est une distance c'est bien
une distance et c'est la distance
parcourue par la lumière en un an et
rien ne va plus vite que la lumière
ça mais je le répète est en fait l'année
lumière c'est la distance parcourue en
un an par le phénomène le plus rapide de
tout l'univers c'est bon j'ai perdu
personne
ok alors on va partir en voyage tous
ensemble avec la lumière la lumière
émise par le soleil m à 8 minutes à
atteindre la terre ce qui est à peu près
la moitié de ce taux que 13 minutes pour
atteindre mars
ici on veut se rendre sur notre étoile
la plus proche on parle de quatre années
de voyage vous et quoi vous il ya quatre
ans alors moi j'étais en tête
je croyais encore que ça se passe très
bien mais bon bref passons à autre chose
bon allons au centre de notre voie
lactée notre galaxie
là on parle d'un voyage de 25 mille six
cent quarante ans vous faisiez quoi vous
il ya vingt-cinq mille six cent quarante
ans à mon avis ça devait être intense
parce qu'on était en pleine ère
glaciaire savez moi j'ai envie d'aller
encore plus loin
j'ai envie d'aller dans la galaxie que
j'ai étudié andromède à 2.5 millions
d'années-lumière 10 6 2
5 millions d'années lumière il ya 2,5
millions d'années
on était en plein paléolithique pendant
la préhistoire et les proto être humain
était à peine en train d'apprendre à
faire des outils ses distances elle
semble difficilement imaginable
eh bien elle et addictions imaginables
même pour les scientifiques
au tout début du xxème siècle une
astronome extraordinaire du nom
d'henrietta les invite à découvert une
technique révolutionnaire pour mesurer
la distance des étoiles lointaines à
l'aide de ces travaux et quelques années
plus tard c'est edwin hubble qui va
mesurer la distance d'andromède et à
l'époque on savait même pas si c'était
vraiment une galaxie la distance qu'il
mesure va de à ce moment là hrw a sonné
tout l'univers et notre vision de
l'univers
andromède était tellement lointaine elle
ne pouvait être qu'une autre galaxie
elle était sa propre galaxie et le ciel
était constellé de galaxies une galaxie
ce sont des milliards des toiles et nous
pensons depuis quelques décennies
qu'autour de quasiment chacune de ces
étoiles
il y à des planètes l'univers n'avait
jamais été aussi gigantesque jamais
aussi étourdissant et nous n'avions
jamais été d'aussi petites choses
fragiles et vulnérables dans une
immensité absolument démesuré mais quel
rapport avec nos conspiration et bien en
connectant les points entre eux le doute
peut alors poindre
n'est-il pas extrêmement improbable que
des aliens qui nous nous cherchent
probablement n'aime pas d'ailleurs et
puis nous trouver dans une telle
immensité
grâce aux connaissances que nous avons
acquise nous avons pu nous ouvrir un
certain esprit critique et ses
connaissances nous déconstruisons à
travers des méthodologies bien rodé mes
collègues et moi même par exemple
cherchons des nuages de gaz des
pépinières des toiles au coeur de la
galaxie andromède afin d' un peu mieux
comprendre l'évolution des galaxies à
l'aide de toute la batterie des outils
et des techniques des scientifiques un
plus ont des statistiques des télescopes
des algorithmes des simulations on a été
en mesure d'analyser doc très grande
quantité de données à notre disposition
de tester des hypothèses et enfin de
construire des études
il est solide il faut les publier afin
que toute la communauté scientifique et
un accès en toute transparence à notre
démarche afin d'avoir un vrai débat
autour de ce que nous avons trouvé et
les débats croyez moi il y en a au terme
de ce processus on peut dire qu'on a
acquis une conviction raisonnable qu'il
ya réellement cp pire des toiles au
chlore d'andromède
je n'irai jamais d'andromède c'est vrai
je n'irai jamais dans andromède vérifier
que mes nuages sont bien réels alors
qu'est ce qui va me distinguer d'un
conspirationnistes qui après tout d'y
faire ses recherches
c'est vrai après tout je ne vais pas
aller sur la lune vérifier qu'on ya posé
le pied
oui parce que figurez vous qu'il y a des
gens qui croient qu'on n'a jamais été
sur la lune et qu'en fait c'est quelque
chose qui a été filmé en studio le plus
simple c'est tout simplement de
contrecarrer parfois la conspiration
puisque les conspirations elles sont
rarement solide pour la lune on peut
tirer un laser et celui ci sera réfléchi
par un réflecteur posait à la surface
par les astronautes côté conspiration le
pinacle de l'argumentaire et ben c'est
de dire que le fameux drapeau américain
planté sur la lune on le voit flotter
dans le vent alors déjà un drapeau qui
flotte dans le vent dans un studio bon
et ensuite après une analyse très très
avancée des photos on se rend compte que
le drapeau les justes tenu par un petit
bateau horizontal et pourtant c'est pas
ça le plus robuste le plus robuste pour
contrecarrer les conspirations c'est
dans les méthodologies il y a dans les
sciences une grande humilité
le savoir n'est pas quelque chose de
binaires et le statisticien d'orge box
10 mm tous les modèles sont faux mais
certains sont utiles ce que cela
signifie c'est que nos savoirs sont en
perpétuelle évolution en débat et ils ne
sont pas figées là où la conspiration on
n'aime pas devoir s'encombrer de
contradictions elle a déjà sa vérité et
s'il faut tordre la réalité pour
l'obtenir
eh ben on va y aller je vais vous donner
un exemple l'une des découvertes les
plus intéressantes qui est ressorti de
cette recherche de pépinière des toiles
qui a occupé des années de ma vie et ma
c'est qu'en fait il n'y avait pas des
masses de pépinière des toiles il y en
avait vraiment très peu dans une région
on s'attendait à en trouver beaucoup
plus et tous les gens qui ont cherché
même s'ils sont cassés les dents
conclusions scientifiques
il n'y a pas de gaz reste à comprendre
pourquoi il n'y a pas de gaz si j'avais
des conspirationnistes là on serait
plutôt tomber dans quelque chose du
genre ah je pense qu'ils aient une
équipe qui a sa beauté mais travaux est
en fait il ya vraiment des pépinières et
on le cache pas c'est parce que
gouvernement pourquoi pas mais on ne
prouve rien en faisant cela
en revanche les sciences et bien même si
elle se met toujours à jour qu'il ya des
débats qu'elles évoluent elles sont
capables de prédire des choses des
décennies voire des siècles à l'avance
par exemple les trous noirs nous savions
qu'ils existaient bien avant d'en avoir
la toute première photo ou encore
galilée au xviie siècle qui propose que
si on lâche un boulet et une plume en
même temps eh bien il devrait tomber
exactement en même temps a en réalité ça
marche pas très bien parce que sur terre
il ya de l'air et du coup la plus belle
va flotter
mais s'il n'y avait pas d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui se passerait alors là on
peut arriver et scientifique moi j'ai
fait une cloche chez j'ai mis du village
de rolle et on est sérieux les
scientifiques fait pas les choses à
moitié on va sur la lune
les astronautes d'apollo 15 dont fait
ils ont pris un marteau une plume avec
eux et sur la lune dans cet
environnement il n'y a que la gravité et
du coup pas d'air que se passe-t-il si
la schl et en même temps eh oui trois
cent cinquante ans plus tôt monsieur
galilée avait raison alors vous me direz
mais vous me direz quel importance
est ce que c'est vraiment grave que des
gens croient qu'on n'a pas été sur la
lune ou que les aliens ont construit les
pyramides
qu'est ce que c'est grave eh bien oui
oui je suis désolé c'est très grave
parce que la curiosité et l'esprit
critique nous équipe contre les
mensonges et les manipulations dans un
monde qui est plein de fake news de
détournement politique et de charlatans
il est important de voir l'impact que
cela peut avoir sur la vie de tous et de
toutes des impacts parfois dramatiques
découvrir les sciences et leur démarche
c'est aussi faire attention aux gens
qu'ils s'emparent de ce terme afin de
les mettre au service de pseudo science
souvent réactionnaire est vraiment très
dangereuse mais alors que faire pour se
prémunir de ces dérives et bien déjà
il serait bon de rappeler mêmes
d'insister sur le fait que les sciences
sont en réalité la voie royale vers
l'émerveillement et vers l'enchantement
je n'ai plus besoin de croire que les
aliens sont cachés parmi nous car notre
univers notre galaxie
notre soleil est notre terre
particulièrement notre terre d'ailleurs
n'ont rien de commun
ils n'ont rien de mondains et ils n'ont
rien d'ennuyeux je dirais même que
s'émerveiller par les sciences c'est
apprendre leur fonctionnement et
s'équiper d'outils de réflexion tout en
rêvant et pour vous en convaincre je
vais vous laisser avec l'une des images
les plus extraordinaires des dernières
décennies et peut-être même de toute
l'histoire
ceci est un tout petit carré noir dans
le ciel l'équivalent d'un bouton de
chemise à 25 mètres on a pointé dans ce
tout petit carré noir le télescope
spatial hubble et dans ce tout petit
carré il a fait une découverte
renversante
ceci est le chant profond de hubble
chacune des petites lumières que vous
voyez est une galaxie et chacune de ces
galaxies
c'est des milliards des milliards des
toiles souvent à des millions peut-être
même des milliards d'années lumière de
nous et nous savons désormais autour de
pratiquement chacune de ces étoiles
il y à des planètes combien d'entre
elles sont susceptibles d'accueillir la
vie
j'ai une excellente nouvelle pour vous
tous nous n'avons aucune idée mais là où
le conspirationniste va vous offrir vous
vendre en fait une réponse séduisante
mais est mensongère les sciences elle
s'attelle à tenter de découvrir ce qui
se passe réellement elle accueille le
doute à bras ouverts et essaye de
comprendre si peut-être il y à un autre
peuple
quelque part qui en ce moment se posent
les mêmes questions que nous ce soir
dans l'une de ces étincelles
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]